comment ça s'est passé cette semaine
bien vient très bien des passements de
jambes aux ongles en passant par les
tirs au but
depuis lundi 12 avril et pour toute la
semaine trente enfants participent au
stage paris saint-germain academy il a
lieu à l'urban soccer de guyancourt
objectif de cette semaine déjà avant
tout c'est de prendre du plaisir parce
que le football ça reste du plaisir et
en même temps de progresser derrière au
fur et à mesure petit à petit des
enfants heureux de pouvoir toucher le
ballon et de profiter des copains malgré
la crise et les journées sont bien
remplies entre 10 heures entre 10 heures
et midi alors ça allait plus est des
exercices tactiques et sans ballon de
motricité aussi de 12h à 14h il ya une
pause donc il se fait à l'extérieur avec
avec les repas et entre 14 heures et 16
heures c'est plus d exercice de
confrontation mais sans confrontation
directe 100 matches ont des activités de
groupe mais non sans restriction ces
héros contact de mettre entre les
enfants une distanciation qui se fait
aussi au niveau des repas des goûters et
durant les matchs et à côté de ça des
mesures sanitaires c'est à dire que tout
se passe à l'extérieur
les enfants jouent à l'extérieur sur le
terrain il mange à l'extérieur et à côté
de ça ils ont aussi un gel
hydroalcoolique oui c'est lave les mains
après chaque entrée et sortie sur le
terrain d'autres stages ont été
organisés par la psg academy à evry
meudon ou encore plus tôt